and uh should we explain who you are or
how do you explain who you are how do I
explain if you met me and I'm just a
dude in the bar how are you explaining
yourself oh gosh do people that don't
know the content yeah like I don't even
know what the red pill is
um I would say I do a live show four
times a week on relationships okay where
men and women argue about relationships
okay interesting all right and so where
are you from I wanna I wanna get the
early backstory so we know where you're
coming from I'm from Chicago okay
where at oh block or a nicer part yeah
I'm from the hood really like Ashley
that'd be pretty cool no no no
um I'm from um it's I probably won't say
the name but it's like 45 minutes from
Chicago okay so um I have nine siblings
I grew up there wow and uh nine siblings
so your parents like religious Maniacs
or what
my mom's catholic but my dad isn't that
religious I don't know they're kind of
he's just like breeding well it's kind
of an interesting
story it's I don't know you want me to
go into it sure okay so I grew up with
six kids in the house and I was the
second out of six so I was the oldest
girl I was between two boys
then when I was 22 I found out I had a
brother that my parents gave up for
adoption so he grew up with like a
different family but he's so I found out
I was like oh I have two older brothers
I don't even know and then
um they adopted three teenagers that
were just in bad situations so like one
kid was homeless on my brother's
football team another one was like or
two because my dad's one of 13 my mom's
one of nine kids I have a lot of cousins
so two were like second cousins that
just weren't in the best situation so
they took in three teenagers um but they
were like 16 when they lived with us so
like they only lived with us for like
two years this seems like very resource
intensive what were your parents doing
that they were able to take care of this
massive community of kids
um so my mom and my dad met when my mom
just got out of high school my dad was a
couple years older and they started a
software company and they did that for
like 25 years and then they sold it
um
well like two years ago maybe okay and
so they're just relatively wealthy off
that that's always been good to them
yeah nice and so how would you describe
how they raised you and what your
upbringing was like
oh it was good um I really enjoyed
having a lot of siblings I feel like
okay I feel like when you're when you
have a lot of siblings
you always know that you ain't because
because they'll make fun of you you know
and then you're always like trying to
get good at stuff because you're like
competing for your parents attention so
I think it's good for children I think
about that a lot of times with my kid
where her entire life up to this point
has been me my girl and everybody else
in our family whatever just praising her
Non-Stop and that yeah like like
sometimes I think about how much she
loves the dog and the cats and it's like
if we didn't have the dog and the cats
knowing now how much she loves them it
feels like I would have been doing her a
massive disservice and now I'm starting
to feel that way about siblings too is
like if I don't give her a brother and
sister I feel like it's gonna be
in a lot in a lot of ways kind of
detrimental like her growing up is the
only child I think it's not ideal how
old is she two do you want more kids
yeah definitely how many at least one
maybe two okay cool yeah
going for nine yeah maybe though I don't
know you know I I it depends how
business goes really I loved it if I
find myself with 50 million dollars
I mean what else am I gonna do you
should honestly I
I love my siblings like I literally um I
don't know what I would do without my
siblings
um yeah I I recommend big families to
anyone that can do it yeah I think
there's something good about it
especially me seeing her family because
they're Armenian so they're like
tight-knit you know and they like help
each other a lot and they're a lot more
like the way you would expect families
to have been throughout most of the
history and like I don't know it's just
there's a lot to that that I see like
the vast majority of people not having
going on these days okay so what was uh
I don't know like what kind of were you
into as a kid or at what point did you
start to find yourself in high school or
whatever
um I was an athlete so a lot of people
don't know this I still play Semi-Pro
volleyball in England wow yeah so that's
that's like how I was always just into
sports I played volleyball basketball
and I ran track in college so that was
like all I cared about when I was a kid
I was just like
yeah really into sports I didn't where'd
you go to college
um Elmhurst College okay in Chicago I
spent a year at Ohio Northern but then I
transferred I don't know anything about
Higher Learning To be honest but they're
small schools most people haven't okay
they're like
no but so
um you're doing sports that was like
your primary focus and I don't know
where do you go from there like what was
College like for you College
um I was just really into sports like
that was the only thing I cared about
for the longest time was just like
getting good at volleyball and I wanted
to take that as far as I could
um and I feel like a lot of kids kind of
get trapped in that that Sports thing
and the reality is that such a tiny
percentage of people have a future in it
professionally or whatever but so many
kids end up being so singularly focused
on that thing for such a huge percentage
of their childhood yeah yeah I was
actually thinking about this the other
day I loved Sports I still do I love
playing but I was thinking I'm like it
is the most useless skill that I have
but it doesn't really impact almost I
mean discipline sure you know there are
elements of it like just working hard to
get good at something in general like
when I look at my bike riding career
quote unquote or like all the time I
spent riding BMX bikes I mean I learned
a ton about life from that but it wasn't
really like the the sport part of it it
was more like the social skills that I
developed from just being out and about
and having to like take care of myself
yeah I would say the biggest like
lessons I learned one was that life
isn't always fair and like you can whine
and complain about your coaches not
playing you or doing whatever but like
my mom would always tell me like you
when you start something you have to
finish it so you can't quit mid-season
like none of that stuff and I would say
it taught me to get along with people
and
um
yeah that's that's the biggest ones
okay so uh at what point does the the
sport dream go away
uh well kind of never I'm still doing it
right but I mean like like when did
other [ __ ] start creeping in um so I
graduated college
um I I got a degree in economics and
business administration I got a
certification in market research then I
worked in sales for two years and I
hated it it was the worst job on the
planet doing what kind of sales oh my
gosh copier you see your copier out
there I was looking at it because they
just bought that everybody has something
to say about it I could tell you if you
got a good deal yeah because
um I sold them for two years and they're
horrible because they're all the same
they're not like how much do you really
think about your copier I have not been
consulted about The copier in any way I
don't I can't even imagine what they are
copying
I would imagine most of this is
happening yeah online it was a horrible
job really yeah and so then I did that
for two years and then I decided to go
to England to play Semi-Pro volleyball
and then I was gonna see if I could play
pro for a year or two
so I got recruited because Semi-Pro was
like you mess in England like you played
in England for a year and then they
recruit you to like Germany or Spain or
whatever okay and then I got my Ma I'm
in the middle of getting my masters like
for that
I didn't really care about the degree I
just like picked something but it was
just like discounted it was like okay
right what kind of living can you make
as a pro volleyball player Oh not see
that was the decision that I had to make
like six months ago because I got
offered a pro contract but it's it's
less than two grand a month for free and
you get free housing and you can work
your way up if you play for a couple
years to maybe three or four like
but that takes so long and like what's
the future in it and so I got offered
like the pro contract in the fall and I
was just like looking at him like I
could move all my equipment and all my
people and all this but it's like for
what had you really thought about how
horrible this career path really was
like throughout your time playing
volleyball that like success would be
not even a living wage
my goal was never to go pro
um I never thought that would be like
I just missed playing so I was like I'll
go play right so it was like I was in
sales for two years and I wanted to do
something else and then I had one
Tick-Tock go viral so I was like oh
maybe I could just be a tick talker
doing what volleyball stuff no oh my
gosh I had a whole like Tick Tock career
before I even did the like the red like
the red pill manosphere type stuff what
was The Tick Tock career
um because everybody's got like a at
least attempted Tick Tock career these
days it feels like well I was almost to
a million on Tick Tock I got to 850 000
and then they took away my account for
what I called a girl a whale
but but she called me ugly first I'd
like to say it was a retaliation right
so she okay I was doing the street
interview and we were talking about
safety and I was saying like I don't
understand why girls walk like they're
always like oh I can't walk home alone
at night I'm like neither can the men no
why are you walking home alone at night
right in a dangerous city I'm like
you're not entitled to safety I've
interviewed infinite people who got shot
and killed or nearly killed just
basically from like walking home at
night
nobody should feel comfortable doing
this in Chicago or L.A I mean you know
you should probably most people should
probably feel comfortable but like if
you have something worth taking
you know which every woman kind of like
inherently does in a way you should
probably be careful about walking on the
night right well and I would argue it's
less safe for men than for women because
because if me and you like both got
attacked right let's you're pretty tall
I feel like they wouldn't maybe if
you're like smaller but time to get left
alone for the most part but let's say
let's say you were like five eight you
know or five ten whatever and it's me
versus you like if a guy gets attacked
like no guy's gonna come and help him
usually but if a girl gets attacked like
I would argue that like more guys are
willing to like come and help and this
was demonstrated during the whale attack
so what happened was this girl got
really mad when I said that so she's
like I'll have you I'll have you you
slag and I was in London I didn't know
what a slag meant I don't know what a
slag is but I knew I was being insulted
insulted right and so so I was just like
whatever you're a whale anyway and then
she's like knocking the mic out of my
hand trying to punch me or whatever and
like I was mad because there was another
guy there the only reason I brought him
was to so so I could not get hit and he
kept letting her back towards whatever
we got on video so but that clip got me
kicked off because I called her a whale
which which is just like she attacked me
first all I did was call her a whale I
hate the idea that you could have called
her an idiot and that that would have
been okay that you can install our
intelligence but that somehow insulting
her the shape of her fat body that
that's over the line and if anything
whales are beautiful majestic creatures
yeah why does that have to even be yeah
who is Tick Tock in there who are they
to be making this decision but what I
meant by whale
I could have meant anything yeah and if
anything I should apologize to the
whales in the sea for comparing them to
fat chicks right yeah you ever seen
Pinocchio
Geppetto who gets swallowed up by a
whale
no I haven't seen it I mean oh okay so
it's a good flick
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible